in a highly charged atmosphere prime
minister's questions began with another
major body blow for boris johnson news
one of his mps christian wakeford had
defected to the opposition party
this following morning newspaper reports
of a widening plot to oust johnson by
members of his own party
jokes at the prime minister's expense
followed
i see the very noise i'm sure the chief
whippers told her to bring their own
booze
salvo after salvo
nobody told the prime minister he was
breaking his own rules
absolutely pathetic if he had any shred
of compassion for all those out there
who've suffered through this he'd go
he's clamoring for explanations from
johnson about the increasing catalogue
of rule-breaking parties that took place
under his watch when the country was
deep in lockdown
but the prime minister seemed energized
fighting tooth and nail for his party
and his job
when the history of this pandemic comes
to be written and the history of the
labour party comes to be written and
believe me they are history and will
remain history mr speaker it will show
it will show it will show that we
delivered while they dithered and we
we vaccinated while they vacillated mr
speaker i am intensely proud of what
this government has done
and call after call for johnson to
resign was met with the same message
to reserve judgment and wait for the
results of the inquiry into a growing
list of rule breaking
but his voices from his own party that
could do the most damage to his
political future mp david davis wants
the theresa may government's chief
brexit negotiator delivering this
surgical strike like many on these
benches i've spent weeks and months
defending the prime minister
against often angry constituents but i
expect my leaders
to shoulder the responsibility for the
actions they take
yesterday he did the opposite of that
so i'll remind him of a quotation
altogether too familiar to him of leo
amory to neville chamberlain you have
sat there too long for all the good you
have done in the name of god go
despite the full force of bran boris
being on show in parliament this was
another bruising day for the prime
minister there's seemingly no escaping
the growing anger from within the
conservative party and with the results
of the potentially damning inquiry
looming johnson's days in office could
soon be numbered neve barker al jazeera
westminster